j'espère qu'il ya huit ans
j'ai suivi un groupe sur le 25 km sur
route et c'était assez agréable voilà
avec rip et recel et non j'étais pas
seule il y avait la petite derrière dans
la carriole c'est un peu plus lourd dans
les côtes
huit parcours au choix allant de 15 à
105 kilomètres pour découvrir le
cyclotourisme dans la vallée de
chevreuse une initiative du vélo club de
montigny le plus gros deal de france
avec plus de 400 licenciés cette année
on a battu notre record de l'an dernier
avec 2002 participants à l'ensemble des
des randonnées qui était proposé
c'est bien d'aider un mot de l'église
pour le bout de chou est intéressant
c'est sympa pour tout pour faire du vélo
un faux pas qui est trop monde en face à
l'as et du monde à l'arrivée du monde et
moment fait d'un coup de folie passé on
passe un autre temps fort de
l'association la monty cyclo au mois de
juin tout au long de l'année le club
organise des sorties à la journée ou sur
plusieurs jours en vélo de route ou en
vtt dès l'âge de 13 ans